you're listening to the Dave Ramsey show
and we're thrilled that you are I'm Ken
Coleman joined in studio by Chris Hogan
as we sit in for Dave Ramsey this hour
taking your calls America about your
life and your money it's a free call
triple 8 8 to 5 5 2 to 5 triple 8 8 to 5
5 2 to 5 now as we went into our last
break I told you that we were super
excited about a brand new study that we
have done we beam Ramsey solutions and
the big finding is that Millennials are
outperforming older generations in
retirement readiness one key piece of
data Chris Hogan that I thought was just
astounding the results from this study
that we recently commissioned said that
58 percent of Millennials are actively
saving for retirement and this has got
to make you happy mr. are IQ 38% already
know how much money they'll need for
retirement now before you go off on that
I just mentioned your mr. r IQ if
they're new the show and they've not
heard us use that term our IQ what does
that mean and how is that relate to you
and how does it relate to that piece of
data yes well our IQ is retire inspired
quotient so you we all want to boost our
eye IQ we want to get smarter well I
want to boost people's IQ on the topic
of retirement I want people to get
smarter about looking at this and
understanding what it is and it is a
free tool that I've put together on my
website at Crystal ghen 360 com that
allows people to get smarter about
retirement by understanding how much is
it going to take for them to live their
dream and so that's what it is Ken what
I like about this study and again it
blew me away and surprised me because
typically if you were to ask baby
boomers or Gen Xers people would have
said that Millennials aren't focusing
all right they say that all the time and
I I would say we have to be careful
lumping people into broad categories you
have people of all demographics that are
more focused than others but I like
hearing that younger people are plugging
into this because the best thing you
could do for your financial future is to
allow time and compound interest to
really start to work and grow your money
and so looking at this and understanding
that Millennials are saving some
are being intentional with what they're
doing is a big deal now the key is going
to be leaving the money there okay
because a lot of people end up putting
money in a 401k and they look at that
like it's a home down payment or a
wedding savings fund and all these
things know when you look at your 401k
or 403b and that way you're treating it
like a savings account you're treating
it like an emergency fund and it's not
your 401k or 403b is your dream account
that's the thing that's going to help
you take care of your financial future
and allow you to do the things you've
wanted to do so the mindset is although
they're saving we got to obviously get
everybody out there Millennials Gen Xers
and baby boomers to get more intentional
and start putting more away you're
joining Ken Coleman and chris hogan here
on the Dave Ramsey show as we talk about
a new Ramsey solution study big headline
that Millennials are outperforming older
generations in retirement readiness now
we've really talked so far Chris about
Millennials and baby boomers and taking
your advice
heating what you said about not painting
people with too broad of a brush
interesting that Generation X which is
our generation you know not really
mentioned until I see this and this is
on one hand you could see Dave smiling
when you read this piece of data and
then it makes me shake my head for our
generation let me tell you what I'm
talking about one of the data points is
that only one in five Millennials are
very confident that Social Security will
be available when they retire now we've
heard Dave rant about that oh yeah
however here's the flipside that Gen
Xers and baby boomers expect Social
Security make up most of their
retirement income there's a disconnect
now you see that right you think it's
going to be there but you're worried and
then you think it's going to be the
majority of what's going to provide for
you yet that to me is a major question
mark and that tells you I think it
really goes to the understanding of what
it is and how it works the big deal is
visual we all know we've been paying
into Social Security as long as you've
had a job and we've all heard about
legislation proposed and all these
changes and I don't know no one out
there has a crystal ball
can tell you absolutely it's going to be
there right if you paid into it I wanted
to be there trust me I want you to get
back what you paid into it but what we
can't do though is rely on it as the
sole source of our income ken did you
know the average Social Security payouts
around 16,000 16,000 years on average
it's based on how much you pay into it
so that equates to thirteen hundred and
thirty three dollars a month can you
live a dream on thirteen hundred and
thirty three dollars a month and a lot
of people small small small dream yeah
it's a game-changer average mortgage
payments twelve hundred dollars and the
average new car payments around five
seventy so you see that just in those
two things the mortgage and the car
payment we've chewed up whatever the
average is for Social Security my point
is this we've got to wake up shake up
and begin to take up our own dreams for
our financial future being able to look
at this and understand small moves will
help us change some things looking at
this study there were seven out of ten
that wish they were saving more okay
from Millennials they wish they were
doing more than what they're currently
doing
I'd say that's across the board for baby
boomers and Gen Xers everybody always
wishes they were doing a little bit more
right for eight and ten planned to save
more in the future so we got wishin and
we got hoping on that as I good wishing
and hoping here's the deal
what we have to do is start doing some
action we got to start sacrificing some
stuff so we can gain some stuff later
the other thing of the study that jumped
out at me were the five obstacles to
millennial saving more in retirement
though this was interesting remember we
got surveyed a thousand people outside
of our tribe people so this is a
absolute kind of a blanket approach to
what America is looking at so five top
obstacles can number one cost of living
is an obstacle stand in a way of people
saving second kids activities now you
and I both have children with that you
can blow a whole budget on that if
you're not careful you're busy I'm look
three student loans fourth credit card
debt and number five of their mortgage
now as we start to look at this and we
start to understand a few things
cost of living now that that phrase
frustrates me because everybody's idea
or a definition of cost of living that
includes a lot of stuff right right and
if we were to boil it down and say your
food your clothing right your housing
and then your transportation these are
the four walls these are things you got
to have right and you start to see and
people have on they're like you know
they eating out and now that's not a
half - right that's a want to right and
so going back and really as a family
making a definition of what is a half -
what do I need versus what I want
because as an adult people I'm going to
tell you adults have to do things
different than kids adults have to be
big enough to tell a wall that it needs
to wait we got to focus and plurk in the
plan people come into the Smart Money
events sitting down talking we help
people deal with all these five
obstacles and I want to help Millennials
remove these obstacles from standing in
the way of them preparing for their
dream you're dropping some major
quotables here I want to go back because
this is so rich you just you just just
roll it along given people advice here
several million people and you don't
understand how good it is well you just
said we have to tell our wants that it
has to wait yeah
oh man that'll preach let's the
sacrifice act really good you know
ediload and I know people are working
hard I know people out there say Chris
you don't understand I worked 48 hours
this week or 75 hours I I deserve to be
able to do some stuff and listen be
careful with that word deserve oh my be
careful see you can't use it can't but
here I'm okay you with you doing some
stuff but people I don't want stuff to
have you I don't want us to be working
hard just to go do some stuff so be
intentional be on a budget go have a
nice dinner go do some things that are
fun but we can't get so caught up in fun
that we forget to chase progress folks
you got to get in on this conversation
it's triple 8 8 to 5 5 2 to 5 a free
call triple-a 8 to 5 5 2 to 5 I'm Ken
Coleman sitting in for Dave Ramsey Chris
Hogan joining me here and one more thing
that you just dropped we when it comes
to retirement you said I wrote this down
this is so good
folks you need to tweet this write it
down put it on your refrigerator stop
wishing and hoping it's dark do it start
doing rapid map I like that that is good
stuff
stop wishing and hoping let's start
doing hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind